le nouvion j'hallucine madame nouvian
s'il vous plaît c'est pas possible on ne
le sait pas parler scientifiquement non
mais ça va pas là
[Musique]
et
je vais plus loïc c'est bien là ou pas
oui mais moi j'ai l'impression d'être
tout petit oui parce qu'après sinon
thomas gauthier fait des vidéos sur moi
là ça va ou pas bonjour
exceptionnellement une vidéo plus
rapidement que d'habitude on n'est pas
mercredi lé pa 6 heures du matin mais
vous avez dû voir ça passait sur ces
news l'émission de pascal praud qui
s'appelle lors des pros il ya une
polémique dessus j'avais envie
d'analyser le truc parce que j'ai vu
beaucoup de choses chez lui et chez les
invités
alors on va faire comme pour la vidéo où
j'avais analysé la gestuelle d emmanuel
macron là on va analyser plus de choses
encore que la gestuelle
je vais pas prendre parti je vais juste
vous dire ce que je vois c'est très
intéressant en fait j'ai lu pas mal de
choses sur twitter mais ce sont des avis
en fait moi je vais pas donner mon avis
c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse c'est de
voir comment réagit pascal praud et
comment réagissent également les autres
personnes comme elisabeth lévy ou claire
nouvian comme d'habitude jeu mais je
coupe et je vous dis ce qui se passe ce
en temps réel
loïc génériques ainsi il ya toujours le
même nom si c'est celui où tu avais fait
une faute d'orthographe la première fois
fabien a put à loïc coat
bonjour à tous et bienvenue se
maintenant l'heure des pros il est là le
réchauffement climatique -3 degrés ce
matin dans les yvelines
à brest on a relevé une température de
moins 0,2 degré aucune valeur négative
n'avait été observée en plus de 75 ans
-1 degrés hier à troyes attention sujet
sensible
on ne rigole pas avec le réchauffement
climatique du coup j'ai demandé à michel
chevalet devient en fait dès le départ
vous avez remarqué il prend pas sa voie
ce qu'on appelle la voie médiatique la
voix du présentateur c'est un peu la
voix que j'ai là quand j'explique des
choses on appelle ça une voie médiatique
dont il ne prend pas du tout au
contraire il prend une petite voix dit
peu rigolote et il est là le
réchauffement climatique
c'est un vrai parti pris de sa part de
traiter le sujet avec humour et on voit
que de toute manière il a il a préparé
le truc par rapport aux sujets qu'on
voit c'est à dire que il est là le
réchauffement climatique où il s'est
déjà d'avant ce qui va parler du fait
qu'ils aient moins 3 ce matin qu'on
n'avait jamais enregistré de valeurs
négatives depuis des années et c est ça
c'est toute la tille de ceux qui vont
être on va dire sur le fait que
il n'y a pas de réchauffement climatique
pour faire très grossir ils sont déjà en
train de sourire
donc ils savent déjà dans quel camp et
l'animateur ça ça me faisait déjà un
problème au tout début de la vidéo par
contre encore une fois ni pour les uns
ni pour les autres quand je décrypte ce
qui me pose problème c'est que
l'animateur fait un travail
journalistique parce que lui se présente
comme étant un journaliste il se doit
d'être factuel et là il donne déjà le
code à cette équipe là qu'il est avec
eux donc ça c'est problématique n'est
pas neutre et on le voit en fait elle
elle se sent déjà agressé par sa claire
c'est normal en fait là pour le coup
c'est tout à fait humain quand tu es
invité il ya une promesse la promesse
c'est un débat le débat c'est que elle
en fait va donner sa position face à
quelqu'un de neutre qui va régir le
débat et à ce moment là
inconsciemment c'est une certitude elle
se dit ah ok donc en fait lui est déjà
dans un parti pris il n'est pas dans la
neutralité
ce qui explique sûrement ce côté un
petit peu rigide où elle le regarde avec
un air un peu renfrogné
je pense que ça vient de ça et ça se
voit d'autant plus qu'un tout petit peu
plus loin il fait une petite blague
encore et voilà vous avez vu ce qu'il
s'est passé ou là c'est carrément des
petits éclats de rire est donc là
forcément on peut pas avoir un peu de
mise en préparation des personnes qui
vont débattre
merci d'être avec nous claire nouvian
vous êtes membre de place publique
vous êtes écologie c'est la première
fois que vous veniez nous voir il la
remercie d'être venus il fait son
travail de là à ce moment là devant la
liste à aucun moment - donné ils la
regardent dans les yeux vous avez je
suis quand même régulièrement des
émissions le moment où la personne doit
te présenter et faire le premier contact
avec toi vis-à-vis des caméras en
général ils regardent me fiche de la
dernière fois pour être sûr de qui vont
pas dire de bêtises et après ils vous
regardent dans les yeux c'est ce qu'on
appelle un accueil vous m'avez vu aussi
dans par l'ancien vidéo j'étais sûr sur
ces huit toute l'importance en fait de
regarder les gens dans les yeux on pense
à se fait automatiquement il n'y a pas
besoin de faire du mentalisme pour ça là
malheureusement s'est pas fait et ça va
toucher d'abord très plaisir que vous
soyez avec nous vous êtes une ancienne
journaliste productrice réalisatrice de
documentaires animaliers scientifique et
en 2004 vous avez fondé l'association
bloom donc je ne peux plus j'ai regardé
l'émission ce que vous avez vu le petit
disque qui rend discrètement regarde
c'est là
[Rires]
discret merci d'être avec nous le
réchauffement climatique il faut pas
blaguer avec ça ici on évoque les teams
des cas à tsonga alors en non verbale il
n'y a pas grand chose à lire parce que
là il incarne un comédien mais c'est
normal il a l'habitude de faire de la
télévision cette émission ça fait deux
ans aussi qu'il lanig donc il est chez
lui il est un petit peu roi à cet
emplacement laon plus précis du plateau
et donc on peut pas analyser le non
verbal par contre on peut analyser son
jeu de comédien et donc par rapport à ce
qui dit il ya un changement climatique
un faut pas rigoler avec ça il fait ce
petit truc de provocation c'est une
provocation on la connaît tous en fait
via l'humour c'est une pique mais plus
ni moins qu il fait à ce moment là avec
son petit truc regarde moi je suis
gentil je dis exactement ce que tu veux
et en fait vous savez même pour vous
très agaçant quand quelqu'un vous fait
ça donc
elle a accumulé l'agacement dont je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure à ce moment
précis est allé déjà un peu trop haute
dans les tours ça c'est une certitude
c'est à dire qu'elle est montée très
vite quelqu'un qui essaye de se
maîtriser mais qui commence déjà à être
énervé avec la main qui va se lever avec
les lèvres passé bon et avec la fameuse
phrase ans il faut arrêter avec ça
michel chevalet va nous en parler moi -3
degrés ce matin dans les emails la
présence de michel chevalet très
intéressante surtout à cet endroit là du
plateau dire que michel chevalet et à
l'endroit de la neutralité sur le
plateau c'est à dire au centre des deux
partisans du débat des deux côtés les
représente une figure d'autorité
scientifique
en tout cas pour pascal praud vous
voulez peut-être pas connu moi quand
j'étais plus jeune
connaissez beaucoup c'était monsieur
science à la télévision c'est lui qui
expliquait tout donc il va représenter
cette légitimité aujourd'hui je suis pas
sûr que ce soit la personne la plus
efficace et la plus au fait est la plus
active dans ce domaine pour être mises
ici il ne m'est pas là c'est pas un
hasard il ne met ici tierces et ça va
être son bouclier sa caution
scientifique entre les parties qui sont
contre ce que louis pense parce que à
cet instant on sait que lui n'est pas
neutre du coup donc il l'a pris ici
comme un bouclier en mode et m
moi je suis neutre moi j'y connais rien
mais c'est mon chef scientifique qui
avec moi sauf que là en faisant cette
blague à michel chevalet en même temps
il vient de créer aussi sa complicité
le code de michel tu es avec moi je sais
pas si lui
il avait décidé je ne pense pas il va
chercher la neutralité mais il ya
conflit d'intérêts amical déjà de base
se tenir entre les deux mais là il lui
rappelle en fait quelle doit être sa
place vis-à-vis du lit donc tous les
deux sens de la place de la neutralité
michel chevalet c'est une certitude va
essayer de la garder mais sans froisser
son ami ce que comme gênant pour un
débat et surtout une fois qu'il a largué
sa blague
sa blague des moins 3 degrés il laisse
même pas le temps aux personnes en phase
de répondre c'est à dire que tu as le
droit de faire une blague et de laisser
le personnes soit rire à ta blague soit
faire une contre blake derrière ou soit
juste faire une réponse normale quoi lui
laisse même pas le temps de faire parce
qu'ils retournent tout de suite le
regard en direction des autres pour
poser une question directe aux donc en
fait il là rien petits colis et il s'en
va ce qui va aussi participer à
échauffer l'autre côté une trottinette
quand même c'est moi je suis grotesque
ne s'était droite c'est pas grave mais
ils sont contents donc madrid rod est ce
que dangereux lui elle est le
présentateur viennent juste de faire une
petite aparté sur les trottinettes ce
qui était intéressant c'était encore
vous de voir la neutralité de pascal
praud c'est à dire qu'elle a dit c'est
grotesque et du coup lui l'a dit oui
c'est grotesque mais ils sont contents
bon ok il a pris une position encore une
fois sur le fait que des adultes face de
la trottinette
on n'est pas sur un truc très argumenté
quand même hein on est juste sur un
oubli subjective de je trouve ça
grotesque complètement fou d'être à 30
ou 40 à l'heure sans casque lampard il
paraît qu'elle fait mal et au dessus de
25 mais qu'elles sont [ __ ] à 25 noeuds
il faut brider bon jeu derrick dhabi je
ne peux petites prothèses quand même
parce que je veux pas pouvoir m'en
empêcher en fait
elisabeth lévy dit mais il paraît
qu'elles sont [ __ ] à plus de 25
kilomètres à la trottinette suis debré
dit non non c'est faux donc voilà il
passe à autre chose en disant c'est faux
si en fait elles le sont elles sont
complètement mais vraiment elles sont
toutes les applications qui met des
trottinettes en place les brides à 25
c'est quand même dommage dans l'absolu
et encore une fois c'est pas un jugement
c'est juste dommage qu'on soit sur une
chaîne qui s'appelle ces news sur une
émission dont qui va donner de
l'information et qu'on compte donne de
la vie et non pas de l'information parce
que des personnes qui regardent la vidéo
qui ne connaissent pas en fait ce
système de 30 minutes je pense à mes
parents par exemple il habitait à la
rochelle sur un milieu de tout ça il
chope sizes ah oui donc ça va à 30 40 km
heure ils viennent de le dire à la
télévision sur ses news
bon ben non qu'on est une figure
d'autorité on se doit de au moins mettre
une nuance c'est ce qu'a fait pour le
coup elisabeth lévy quand elle dit tarek
el sont [ __ ] à plus de 25
voilà elle sait pas trop donc elle met
une nuance là dessus donc après il faut
surtout pas dire non non c'est pas vrai
non bah si c'est vrai dans le temps donc
on met de la nuance qu'on sait pas mais
autorise pas ça tout simplement ridicule
par exemple non mais en fait ça m'est
complètement égal le ridicule si
maintenance et les solutions assez
intéressant les jugements de valeur sur
les gens qui font ce qu'ils veulent
sabic la mi temps mais c'est l'espèce
qui a perdu un peu on voit quand même
que la par exemple les dix bêtes lévis
c'est elle qui attaquent en fait il lui
fait une question orientée l'animateur
et développement vous trouvez pas ça
ridicule vous quand même les
trottinettes baril a pas demandé qu'est
ce que vous pensez des trottinettes ai
dit vous trouvez pas ça ridicule donc
question orientée donc elle forcément en
plus comme à les écolos elle joue sa
partie c'est-à-dire qu'elle dit non je
trouve que c'est la mobilité douce de
demain et caetera et commença en
rigolait donc elle elle donne pour le
coût de la vie de ce qui vient de se
dire précisément à 10 mois
en fait je ne porte pas de jugement sur
les choses je ne constate que les
solutions aux gays c'est intéressant de
dire ça tu vois pas ce que à ce moment
là elle est en train de les protéger
elle ne peut pas les attaquer et
elisabeth lévy dit non non il n'y a pas
de jugement de valeur sur les choses là
on aura juste que blablabla ya pas de
jugement des autres quelques secondes
avant
remettez ma vidéo en arrière vous allez
voir c'est quand même elle qui dit voilà
ils sont grotesques c'est ridicule ils
sont grotesques donc si c'est un
jugement en s'énervant en disant que
j'ai jamais portée du jugement
elle envoie pas un bon signal à ce
moment là parce que si elle l'a dit je
pense que elle même vient déjà d'oublier
qu'elle l'a dit donc en fait on est en
train d'avoir exactement les problèmes
de communication toute la base en fait
de la braise de ce qui va s'enflammer
par la suite un autre jugement
alors c'est que nous avons beaucoup de
malades aux urgences a par contre ça m'a
énormément plu avec les protéines et
d'actes la régulation tout soit ok là on
voit claire nouvian qui rentre dans
l'acceptation d'un vrai argument puisque
lui il vient de donner des arguments sur
les accidents etc et on la voit accepter
le truc donc on voit qu'il n'ya pas
encore de litige entre deux et ça c'est
une bonne chose je trouve que c'est bien
des deux côtés
ça montre que tout ceux qui sont de ce
côté là de la table sont pas encore où
sont peut-être même pas du tout on verra
par la suite agressif et on voit aussi
que claire nouvian est capable de faire
la séparation des choses donc on voit
que ça va plus être un problème
d'arguments mais un problème entre des
êtres humains en fait ne vous intéresse
pas ça va être compliqué surtout
l'émission a dû tout machin jugement
elle se fait réattaquer par elisabeth
qui vient juste de dire donc là on l'a
le langage non verbal classique de crac
crac crac je me ferme je peins c'est je
pense un petit peu la tête je me demande
juste est-ce que vous avez l'intention
de discuter du 10 pbs et des annonces
cet après midi de ce qui va se passer
pour la biodiversité puisque on a quand
même un événement à paris internationale
tout le monde va regarder cet après-midi
paris vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
sur son parole
elle est donc en train de demander si on
va parler de ça ça ça pourquoi elle fait
ça c'est pas on voit pour faire sa
première de la classe elle est plutôt
même inquiète on le voit dans le regard
c'est parce que très clairement ça se
voit à la était invité pour parler de ça
au départ ça a été son angle
d'invitation donc elle s'en inquiètent
en fait à savoir est ce que vraiment on
va parler de ça ou est-ce qu'on va juste
me faire des blagues sur le changement
climatique
donc elle elle cite l'événement en
l'occurrence est là quand elle va dire
que c'est un événement majeur regarder
vraiment il la regarde
il la regarde ils écoutent ils vont
acquiescé quand on va dire que c'est un
événement majeur donc ils sont d'accord
avec elle elle croise les bras elle la
regarde plus n'acquiesce pas je pense
que là à partir de ce moment là soit il
fallait bas ne plus faire ce débat soit
il fallait sortir
elisabeth lévy du débat puisqu'elle
n'est plus là pour débattre a là un
problème d'êtres humains avec claire
nouvian dit paris est ce que c'est un
l'ordre
jour bonjour non je vous le demande non
j'ai pas je ne suis pas au courant de ça
il a perdu ses fiches
et du coup il lui répond et fait nan nan
on parlera pas de ça et puis je ne sais
pas où j'ai mis mes fiches donc jusqu'au
bout et mon conducteur c'est mal fait
c'est gênant parce que ils envoient
encore un autre signal qu'un signal la
maintenance d'humiliation c'est à dire
qu'il répond à sa question primaire sa
question primordiale ce pourquoi elle
était invitée sans la regarder une
nouvelle fois avec un petit il prend la
chose à la légère et je pense pas que ce
soit voulu de sa part à ce moment là
mais donc ils la regardent pas pour
répondre à cette question importante
surtout que sa réponse est non et en
plus j'ai perdu mon conducteur ce qui
est son instrument de travail
donc c'est comme si vous vous habillez
un plombier chez vous qui est censé
réparer quelque chose par exemple
et puis ça fuit ça fuit et puis vous
dites mais là vous vous aller réparer et
vous regarde pas il fait non non et puis
je sais pas où j'ai mis ma clé à molette
donc je crois pas voilà c'est exactement
ce qu'elle ressent donc c'est un petit
peu humiliant bon alors j'ai un peu dans
la tête ce qu'on doit faire
sinon je peux vous raconter janot geab
bon donc là elle essaie toujours de
jouer sa partie de dire sinon je peux
combler et je vais vous dire des choses
intéressantes
en fait ces cavaliers de sa part
évidemment là je comprend en tout cas la
personne pourquoi elle fait ça je dis
pas que c'est bien ou pas bien mais elle
se dit ok il n'a pas prévu d'en parler
moi je suis là pour ça donc pendant
qu'ils se cherchent ces fiches peut-être
je peux qu'aller un mot à ce sujet donc
lui dit non par exemple ce qui se passe
cet après midi alors c'est quand même là
il ya une conférence de presse avec 150
ex delarue nommé le savent aujourd'hui
pas que ce soit vrai que là la partie
intéressante entre les deux il se
positionne en fait à sa place ici c'est
à dire le roi de l'émission c'est son
émission où ils disent ça vous dérange
pas que ce soit moi qui décide des
sujets dont on parle un peu pour
médiatique parce que elle elle se
rabaisse derrière parce qu'elle sait
qu'elle a tort d'avoir essayé de faire
ça c'est que halal à jouer quelque chose
mais que c'était pas normal de le faire
comme elle le faisait à ce moment là et
lui ça lui donne un pouvoir immense il
se repositionne à ce moment là sauf que
dans les excuses qu'elle fait
ça va faire enfler encore une fois sa
légitimité et en plus de ça il ne prend
pas en considération par contre le fait
qu' il a perdu son conducteur est elle
dit qu'elle vient parler de ça il ya
vraiment un problème d'organisation dans
les égouts dans la manière de
communiquer mais aussi dans la
construction de l'émission en elle même
parce que l'analyse de l'émission d'un
composteur c'est a priori c'est plus à
l'émission j'arrivais vous prenez le
pouvoir directement
ça c'est la phrase en trop vous arrivez
et puis vous prenez le pouvoir on est
sur la taxe d'après excuses c'est à dire
que quand quelqu'un fait une bêtise il
va s'excuser et la personne en face à
l'as deux manières de réagir soit
l'acceptent des excuses et elle passe
outre elle peut aussi accepter des
excuses mais en fait ça lui laisse une
trace mais là il n'accepte pas vraiment
les excuses il les entend il les prend
et va recharger derrière et là on rentre
dans un schéma d'humiliation il n'y
avait pas repréciser ça derrière c'est
pas un bon schéma de communication et
encore une fois je vous rappelle qu'il
représente la neutralité à ce moment là
en battant quelqu'un m'a dit dans les
coulisses vient de dire moi on m'a dit
en coulisse à l'as le pouvoir c'est
qu'il faut prendre la parole dans
l'émission et c'est en fait pour encore
une fois moi aussi faire des émissions
je peux vous dire on est briefé en fait
sur le ton qu'on a le droit d'adopter ou
pas en plateau sur attention vous n'êtes
jamais venu faut pas hésiter à répondre
aux auteurs font plutôt laissé parler
quand c'est pas votre tour et où donc
elle a été briefé en fait pour agir
exactement comme elle vient d'agir sauf
que lui cce il sait que c'est vrai parce
que il sait comment c'est passé
l'émission donc il va avoir une tactique
tout à fait naturel dès qu'elle a fini
sa phrase plutôt de commenter ça il
donne la parole tout de suite à
quelqu'un qui ne l'a pas demandé il y en
a qui andré citroën il ya des travaux je
le dis tous les matins oui bien pas on
peut plus passer on peut plus circuler
darwin il ya personne d'ailleurs mérité
petite parenthèse parce que c'est un
petit peu rigolo vous avez pas vu tout
ce qui est des avances à reparler des
trottinettes et des pistes cyclables à
vous avez entendu ce qu'ils viennent de
dire il faudra grosso modo 10 les pistes
cyclables on n'en manque pas là que
j'avais les cils andré citroën jeudi
tous les matins c'est infernal
el haddioui rue de rivoli c'est pareil
moi pareil tous les jours et c'est par
contre ça va démontrer quelque chose
d'aussi d'intéressant pour le futur
c'est à dire leurs propres expériences
prime sur l'analyse globale dire que si
puisqu'il dit tous les jours sur
lesquels andré citroën c'est à dire que
tous les jours il passe par là donc le
fait que cette piste cyclable là
existent et en plus le dérange et qu'à
l'heure où une passe lle personnes
dessus
pas grand monde j'imagine ça devienne
réalité globale pour tout paris pour
toute la france pour toutes les heures
c'est pas une bonne analyse c'est pas un
travail de journaliste à ce moment là
que de dire ça et il a du répondant avec
lui en fait en la personne d'elisabeth
juste un mot quand même sur sur cette
histoire de réchauffement climatique
parce que il fait moins 3 degrés dans
paris donc nous sommes amusés où il fait
pas bon pourquoi il fait froid donc
michel chevalet va nous expliquer
pourquoi il fait froid ce matin et je
peux vous le m 1 je mettrai un lien vers
les missions complètes dans la
description fabien pense à mettre le
lien sinon après m'être des commentaires
c'est pas bon comme méthodologie à ce
moment là et ça aussi ça va terminer de
mettre le feu aux poudres
vous le verrez plus tard en expliquant
pourquoi il fait froid ce matin on
n'explique pas pourquoi il ya un
changement climatique
et ça c'est un souci comment vous dire
parce que ça déplace le problème
comme si le fait d'expliquer pourquoi il
faisait froid ce matin
remettez du coup en cause le changement
climatique actuel et le bouleversement
climatique actuel donc encore une fois
je ne sais pas je ne pense pas que ce
soit conscientiser comme ça dans la
mécanique mais c'est comme ça que ça
donne un résultat erroné de dire que si
la température descend et qu'en même
temps moi je prend en compte le nombre
de fois que loïc fait une blague dans la
journée et que je m'aperçois que plus il
fait des blagues crues il fait froid
mais moi aussi je peux dire loïc à de
faire des blagues ce que plus tu fais
des blagues plus il fait froid c'est sûr
j'ai calculé les deux et ça marche bon
ben là c'est un petit peu en de ce qu'on
est en train de faire on dit bon alors
pourquoi il fait froid ce matin et lui
il va expliquer pourquoi il fait froid
que c'est naturel en fait qu'il fasse
froid et en à la conclusion de ab voilà
donc ya pas de changement climatique
donc c'est pas du tout la bonne
méthodologie est ce que vous diriez que
depuis 30 ans
deux sur deux dans le monde il y à un
dérèglement climatique oui ou non à une
modification des règlements il ya une
modification dont qui lui pose la
question lui dit ben oui oui il ya une
modification des règlements en fait sont
des règlements sais je sais pas et je
vais pas prendre parti et je ne n'ai pas
assez de compétences et de connaissances
à ce moment là pour le faire et en plus
je vois je sens bien que mon pote a pas
envie que je dise mais par contre je
peux pas dire des âneries donc il est en
train de changer le terme ans il ya des
modifications des règlements
modifications les deux stienne pourquoi
pas un climat de ces banques qui n'ont
pas le droit de parler quand on veut
faire une émission il ya des gens qui
finalement y'a plus climat social y en a
beaucoup
voilà alors la lie et c'est parti on
avait michel chevalet qui disait donc
non non non c'est pour ça que l'on a
desservait ce n'est pas à cause du
dérèglement climatique il fait froid ce
matin mais personne n'avait dit ça c'est
encore le résultat de d'être une
problématique qui a été complètement
déformée mais personne n'avait dit ça
sur plateau ni lui ni personne personne
ensuite lui il s'est juste accroché à ce
qu'ils cherchaient depuis le départ à
savoir que le conflit en fait on le sent
bien et là on est parti a le menton
relevé et s'est avancé au top du top en
plus comme les rois
il l'a dit il lui dira baisse toi c'est
exactement le signal qu'il envoie en dix
ans donc les climato en plus doit parler
elle elle dit il ya plus de
climato-sceptiques ci lui dit si s'il y
en a et en fait et fait effectivement
non le climato sceptiques c'est à dire
un climatologue sceptiques bayonne il y
en a plus en fait les gens qui sont
sceptiques sur le fait qu' un
dérèglement climatique ne sont pas
climatologue ne sont pas des
spécialistes du climat
justement ce que des personnes qui ne ce
qu'ils ne sont pas exactement
spécialistes du climat
donc il ya pas de climato sceptiques en
réalité dans dans l'essence même du mot
oui un climato sceptiques c'est
quelqu'un qui en vrai serez
climatologues en vrai non mais tu as
raison de poser le truc parce que vous
allez me le dire dans les commentaires
en vrai nom c'est pas ça le le le
le vrai mot de base mais aujourd'hui
c'est ça c'est à dire que y'a pas un
climatologue sceptiques donc le terme
climato sceptiques ne peut pas exister
par essence puisque tous les
climatologues s'accordent à dire qu'il
ya des grosses modifications en fait
dans le climat là on va dire que je
prends parti dans la vidéo mais c'est
vraiment pour expliquer sur ta question
en fait aujourd'hui on devrait dire il
ya des négationnistes du changement
climatique ce serait plus juste en fait
de dire ça tu vois il ya un consensus
effectivement sur la réalité du
changement sur ses causes et sur son
évolution non et vous vous aimez que si
vous vous aimez comme un certain benoît
de gentils que les prévisions en fait
vous voyez pourquoi pourquoi ça
s'échauffe vraiment seront une histoire
d'êtres humains la terre que là pour
débattre
elle va utiliser encore une fois de faux
arguments un petit peu comme ça a été
pour le dépassement pour la vitesse là
trottinent qu'elle lit voilà il ya un
consensus aujourd'hui qui est d'accord
pour dire qu'il ya des modifications du
climat sur ses causes et sur son
évolution
non claire nouvian pète un câble
derrière elle pète un cap parce que à la
connaissance du fait que c'est faux et
comme elle n'a pas mis de nuances dans
ce qu'elle dit par exemple il me semble
qu'on n'est pas sûr de ses causes et de
son évolution je crois ça se seraient
passées différemment pas beaucoup
différemment mais quand même
différemment sauf que là je sais pas si
elle si elle admet au fond d'elle
qu'elle sait pas mais je pense pas parce
qu'on a quand même tout un signe d'une
vraie colère sur son visage etc
on voit vraiment un combat avec lync le
cookie second flux tous pareils la tête
tu remontes les yeux écarquillés on
cherche à faire peur on cherche à
apprendre de la place faisait comme les
oiseaux quand il est temps de leur zèle
ou les chats quand ils lisent eris leurs
poils tout ça c'est pour prendre du
volume au combat c'est ce qu'elle fait
elle pas grand chose à dire elle a
vrillé et du coup elle ne pourra jamais
récupérer le débat elle elle perd la
crédibilité alors peut-être pas
vis-à-vis du grand public je sais pas
encore ce que vous en pensez par exemple
à ce que le grand public en pense mais
encore une fois j'agis en outre alité à
ce moment là mais à perdre la
crédibilité auprès des autres personnes
peut-être un petit peu près lui qui se
détournent aussi
pour pas la regarder elle mais bon
j'espère qu'elle avait encore de la
crédibilité quand même auprès des autres
puisqu'il y avait des tentatives
d'attaqués
c'est à dire parce qu'ici c'est ici on
laisse dire des choses avec lesquelles
on n'est pas d'accord pour l'instant si
vous remarquez objectivement personnes
d'aller si claire nouvian dire les
choses qu'elle est venue dire et pour
lesquels elle a été invitée
franck c'est problématique mais vous et
au nord là elle vient de dire quelque
chose
elle vient de dire mais c'est dingue
mais vous êtes dingues de dire des
choses comme ça on le sait elle vient
pas de la traiter de folle s'est passé
pas ça c'est encore une fois c'est une
réaction épidermique on voit vraiment
que c'est pas une insulte on voit en
fait que c'est juste un choc
en fait elle elle se dit attends comment
ça se fait que à la télé on puisse dire
sur une chaîne comme ses news quelque
chose que moi je sais faut
scientifiquement jeu puisque à priori
les clubs dans son domaine elle pour
dire ça et du coup elle s'est dit mas et
de la désinformation qui en train de se
passer c'est dingue pas une insulte et
donc elisabeth lévy le récupère pour
dire vous êtes en train de m'insulter là
vous êtes en train de m'insulter
c'est de la récupération de quelque
chose qui n'était pas destinée sur une
insulte sur sa personne
diaby dont vous êtes temps nous 21e
siècle
non mais ça suffit c'est bien non mais
c'est pas d'emblée si vous me laissez
pas parler jamais cultivé
scientifiquement
donc là le prends comme une insulte
l'impasse allez vous cultivez
scientifiquement je vois pourquoi il dit
ça encore une fois je pense qu'elle
aurait plus à gagner à tempérer à se
taire et c mais ma foi elle est là les
parties allaient aller trop loin de mer
elle est parée table elle va s'en servir
elle pour servir sa cause à tort ou à
raison mais ça va être un argument pour
être la leur revient sûr si vous
continuez avec les insultes je me par
bon allez vous cultivez scientifiquement
jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est pas
une insulte non nouvion j'ai lu ici
madame nouvian s'il vous plaît c'est la
première fois que je voudrais d'abord
que vous qualifiez de classer un des
derniers passages que je vais analyser
parce qu'il est représentatif du reste
en fait donc ça s'échauffe et grave
entre on va dire elisabeth est éclair
pour faire plus court
elles se sont elles fait faillite elle
se fight encore une fois à tort ou à
raison pour l'une ou pour l'autre peu
importe
lui qui représente la neutralité vous
l'avez déjà vu dans les débats les gens
faire calmez vous calmez vous comme ça
avec les mains des deux côtés tout le
monde reprend ses esprits lui prend une
position direct aussi bien corporelle
aussi bien dans les attitudes et aussi
bien que dans la voix puisqu'il dit
madame nouvian madame nouvion madame
nouvian madame nouvian calmez-vous
puisqu'apparemment elisabeth lévy est
complètement calme là a priori donc non
il aurait dû au dire de se calmer et il
a l'art abaissé une nouvelle fois
l'argument qui n'a rien à voir qu'il dit
c'est la première fois que vous venez
ici mais je dire c'est un débat d'air du
bon sens fouquet cela depuis une fois ou
deux puis mille fois c'est à dire que
peu importe le nombre de fois qu'elle
est venue c'est calme et vous quelle
belle j'ai envie de vous dire dans ces
cas-là elisabeth lévy aurait aussi
peut-être dû lui dire et vous madame
lévis vous êtes habitué à venir et à
débattre il me semble ça aurait pu être
sur les deux pour les calmer les deux
mais on est sur un full sur une personne
et là on a la première insulte et il est
10 31 donc on voit toute la rage est
venu qui sortit d'elle elle n'a pas pu
le retenir vous voyez le juriste plus
d'avancé comme à l'envoi lille mais ces
fous qui est folle hélas la première
insulte est lâché en fait c'est la
première vraie insulte de l'émission
c'est elisabeth lévy qui dit à claire
nouvian c'est vous qui êtes folle mois
elle le dit elle le lâche tranquillement
mais j'imagine que pascal praud va
falloir mettre en place ces banques est
dingue n'ont été aussi bas oui vous
voyez
parce qu'après à lui dit mais c'est vous
qui est dingue hélas il était bon et
arrêter aussi voit donc elle ce recul
elle se referme
elle arrête vous laissez parler les gens
et donc comme il vient à tout petit peu
de larmes et à sa place du café mais
enfin depuis tout à l'heure vous vous
empêcher les gens de dire ce qu'il pense
en fait c'est la phrase qui l'a dit
avant et parce qu'elle sait qu'elle va
se recoller à son état d'esprit
effectivement il récupère ça pour lui
redire la même chose vous laisser parler
vous laissez parler les gens il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont scientifiques
et qui sont climato sceptiques mais ça
n'existe plus non ne dites pas ça madame
alors je demande à monsieur donc là sur
le seul truc sur lequel il n'a pas le
terrain on le voit est donc lui il
rattrape le bret un copain donc la
réponse est un nul effet michel mimi y
en a où il y en a pas et lui du coup bas
il fait si si il y en a ils sont de
moins en moins mais il y en a quand même
lui va se contenter de ça se retourne et
dire voilà c'est exactement ce que je
dis oui mais non mais michel on voit que
je suis pas sûr encore une fois que ce
soit la personne la plus compétente à ce
moment là et est donc c'est un bouclier
encore une fois deux partis pris c'est
une petite arme bouclier c'est les deux
ce que j'essaye de vous dire c'est que
vous validez comme tout le monde moi je
parle des conséquences et de la passion
de lutter contre il y a des gens s'ils
voulaient qui comme vous vendent une
sorte de religion avec l'idée si vous
voulez qu on inventera jamais rien je
veux dire de nouveau si c'est vous
vendez une religion
et à vous entendre on devrait plonger
dans la guerre civile
on devrait mettre des millions donc en
danger
on va on va s'arrêter là dessus parce
qu'après ça plus trop d'intérêts ça va
tourner en boucle puisque là on part sur
les arguments fallacieux on met des
choses dans la bouche des gens qui n'ont
pas été dit à savoir que s'inquiéter du
climat ce serait une religion en fait
donc c'est quand même très grave on
parle de cire ans 1/2 de mêlée
le terme religion comme si c'était une
croyance en fait et après aller selon
vous à vous entendre on devrait plonger
dans la guerre civile
et c est en fait là c'est terrible c'est
à dire que encore une fois elle met des
mots dans la bouche de quelqu'un et en
englobant d'autres personnes qui sont
pas là donc à partir de ce moment là le
débat ne peut pas avoir lieu
il va continuer à se passer tout ce
qu'on a vu depuis tout à l'heure mais ça
va être de pire en pire c'est à dire que
les humiliations seront plus fortes les
confrontations seront plus forts les
arguments sont fallacieux serons plus
forts voilà je trouvais ça intéressant
de faire ça je vais pas analyser le
clash en fait ça n'a pas d'intérêt
d'analyser le clash complet là on y est
vraiment à 11 27
ce qui était intéressant c'est de voir
pourquoi c'était sûr qu'on allait y être
depuis le départ pourquoi parce que les
rôles ont peut-être mal été défini la
pluie les promesses n'étaient pas bonnes
et du coup c'est un problème entre êtres
humains plus qu'un problème d'arguments
en fait peu importe qui a raison qui a
tort
chacun se fait son avis c'est pas un
problème mais si les règles du jeu ne
sont pas bien posée et que tout le monde
a les mêmes règles du jeu dans les mains
alors ça ne pouvait arriver qu'à ça
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
intéressé vous pouvez vous abonner comme
d'habitude en cliquant là vous pouvez
également vous abonner à la chaîne
secondaire en cliquant ici tient ça ça
fait plaisir
ici il y à la vidéo la dernière qui
sortit serre sur la terre plate ou
rondes d'ailleurs et ici il y a une
autre vidéo qui devrait vous intéresser
moi je vous dis à très bientôt mercredi
prochain six heures comme d'habitude
ciao
au revoir